Introduction
When directors tell origin stories derived
from comics, there’s always a montage showing
how the main character comes to develop their
super-suit.
That’s because costume is central to any
hero’s identity and how audiences connect
with them.
Costume designers face an uphill battle right
from the start, as fans can be pretty vocal
about what they expect.
It can also be really hard to engineer an
outfit that will withstand the realities of
filming.
Plus, whatever suit they decide on will forever
be enshrined in the superhero lexicon- for
better or for worse.
No pressure.
But one thing is understood; the costumes
will not be comfortable.
Every actor lucky enough to wear one knew
exactly what they were getting themselves
into, but did it anyway.
Because opportunities to be super don’t
come around everyday.
Here are 10 Amazing Actors Who Hated Their
Superhero Costumes.
Ryan Reynolds, The Green Lantern
CGI is a beautiful thing.
It makes new worlds spring to life and bring
people back from the dead.
But when executed poorly, it spoils the whole
experience- regardless of who is in front
of the camera.
Case in point: Hal Jordan’s suit in the
2011 flop The Green Lantern.
Computer generated from head to toe, fans
lost their minds about how ridiculous it looked.
But nobody hated the outfit more than the
guy wearing it: Ryan Reynolds.
Thankfully, it wasn't the actor’s last time
super-suiting up.
And came back to the big screen in Deadpool.
Which, if you watch closely, takes a few jabs
at his past work.
The actor has also stated that he’s thankful
Deadpool wears a physical suit instead of
a CG one: the kids he visits with the Make
A Wish Foundation are far more excited to
see a real costume than the alternative motion-capture
pajamas he wore for the filming of The Green
Lantern.
Margot Robbie, Suicide Squad
Fans (and Screen Rant writers!) are all eagerly
awaiting the release of Suicide Squad later
this summer.
With killer teams both in front of the camera
and behind it, the movie is sure to be a success.
But for actress Margot Robbie, the journey
has been a cold one.
Playing Harley means wearing the clothes that
fit with the iconic character’s personality.
And in this case, that means booty shorts,
a baseball tee, and some bitchin’ stilettos.
The costume is quite striking, especially
beside her heavily-clothed cast-mates, but
the actress is quick to remind people that
there’s a definitive line between where
she ends and her character begins.
One scene required her to be soaking wet,
and when the crew broke for lunch, she ate
a burger in her clingy wet costume.
If any of us were in her shoes, we’d feel
self-conscious too.
Jennifer Lawrence and Rebecca Romijn, X-Men,
X-Men 2, X-Men: The Last Stand, X-Men: First
Class, X-Men: Days Of Future Past, X-Men:
Apocalypse
Fans have been drawn to the X-Men franchise,
in part, because of the diversity of characters.
Each mutant manifests their power in a personalized
way, and bringing those radical characters
to life takes incredible dedication behind
the scenes.
These transformations aren’t just hard on
the makeup team, they take a toll on the actors
too.
Both Rebecca Romijn and Jennifer Lawrence
have played Mystique, everyone’s favorite
shapeshifter and one of the series’ most
visually stunning characters.
The actresses were both covered in prosthetics
and paint applied directly to their skin,
in a process that usually took about seven
hours every day.
After Lawrence had a medical reaction to the
paint, they finally created a suit for her
to wear instead.
Mercifully, that cut her time in the makeup
chair down to only 3 hours.
If only Romijn could have been as lucky.
Paul Bettany, Captain America: Civil War
According to Paul Bettany, spending 20 hours
a day with rubber glued to your face is kind
of an uncomfortable experience.
As Vision, Bettany is decked out in a full
suit from tip to toe, which had a tendency
to get pretty warm.
But what audiences can’t see are the tubes
underneath, pumping ice water around the actor’s
body to cool him off- a trick used for most
of the heroes appearing in film.
But that didn’t help him in the nearly four
hours each day it took to get into costume.
A costume that, he says, he can rip off in
under a minute at the end of the day.
As for the rest of his day?
The stunt team had two pieces of advice for
him and co-star Chadwick Boseman to stay sane
in their uncomfortable costumes: reading and
meditation.
And when it got really bad, Bettany says he
reflected on how many actors would kill to
be in his position, and his discomfort became
replaced with gratitude.
Andrew Garfield, The Amazing Spider-Man
With all the superhero movies being released
these days, costume designers have been working
overtime to take some of the most complicated
designs from the page to the screen.
And they’ve become pretty innovative as
a result.
A good costume makes it easy to forget that
its being worn by a real person, who has real
bodily functions.
And Andrew Garfield’s first spidey suit
from The Amazing Spider-Man is a good example.
While it was full of technology, the only
way the actor could go to the bathroom was
to take it off completely- no easy feat when
the suit is engineered to be skin-tight.
Thankfully, the designers heard Garfield’s
feedback, and added a zipper to the next generation
of costumes.
Nature’s call wasn’t the only obstacle
in his way, apparently the mask was really
hard to see out of.
But since Spidey’s mask and eye shape are
basically his trademark, everyone agreed that
low visibility was a price they were willing
to pay in order to stay true to the character.
Malin Akerman, Watchmen
No matter how literal the adaptation, filmmakers
take a risk when they decide to take a story
from a graphic novel and turn it into a movie.
Someone always gets hurt.
But regardless of where you stand on Zac Snyder’s
Watchmen, you have to admit that the costumes
are dead on.
And while that made fans really happy, it
was hard on Malin Akerman.
As Silk Spectre II, Akerman had to wiggle
into a suit made of latex, which she compared
to wearing a rubber band.
The actress has also said that Spectre’s
suit would magnify the temperature of whatever
room she was in: making her either freeze
or overheat depending on the conditions.
Add a corset and heels to that equation and
the result is a bad time.
Ben Affleck, Batman vs. Superman: Dawn of
Justice
When it came time for Christian Bale to pass
the bat-torch to Ben Affleck, he had one piece
of advice: “make sure you can piss in the
suit.”
And, as we heard earlier, that’s a sentiment
that Andrew Garfield would agree with.
Going into the filming of Batman v Superman
armed with that advice also led to co-star
Henry Cavill’s super-suit being modified
to meet the new criteria as well.
But that isn’t the Batsuit charged with
cramping Affleck’s style, it’s the heavily
armored alternate suit that’s to blame.
It looks unbelievably bad ass in the final
cut of the film, but in reality it was way
less cool.
The actor wore a baggy motion-capture suit
during these scenes which helped engineers
later manipulate the scene with CGI.
And, as it turns out, fighting in ill-fitting
pajamas against the Man of Steel can be a
little embarrassing, especially if you’re
expected to brood at the same time.
Ron Perlman, Hellboy, Hellboy II: The Golden
Army
Ron Perlman has been in the business for a
long time, but audiences will recognize him
from his roles in shows like Sons Of Anarchy
or Hand Of God.
And we’ll be seeing more him in the upcoming
Fantastic Beasts And Where To Find Them.
But one place they might not recognize him
from is his work as the character Hellboy-
and thats exactly the point.
The makeup process was so extensive that by
the time he was done in the trailer, only
his eyelids were left exposed.
With everything else either covered by prosthetics,
foam, or several coats of red paint.
The actor admits he grew tired of the process
pretty quickly, but stuck it out because he
loves the character.
Hopes for a third installment have been swirling
for years, many of them belonging to Perlman
himself.
But unfortunately, at this point, it doesn’t
seem very likely.
Chadwick Boseman, Captain America: Civil War
Audiences have been waiting a long, long time
for Black Panther to show up on the big screen.
So when it finally happened earlier this year
in the super-anticipated Captain America:
Civil War, fans got excited.
Brought to life by Chadwick Boseman, the character’s
suit keeps the actor completely contained
within.
And considering the movie was filmed over
a pretty hot summer, it wasn’t very comfortable.
The outfit is made of many intricately detailed
pieces, and Boseman admits he was pretty concerned
about accidentally scratching any one of them
and making more work for the costume department.
But that’s something he’s going to have
to get over, and pretty quickly too, since
a Black Panther solo movie has been greenlit
for a 2018 release.
Plus, now that he’s been introduced to the
Marvel cinematic universe, there’s no telling
how many movies he’ll show up in.
Despite all this, Boseman has stated time
and time again that he feels honored to be
part of the team.
Olivia Munn, X-Men: Apocalypse
Olivia Munn has been orbiting the comic scene
for years, since her days hosting G4’s Attack
Of The Show.
And she’s come a long way since, even landing
herself the role of Psylocke in the latest
X-Men installment, Apocalypse.
Munn’s passion for the source material and
her love of the character are what she would
focus on every day while both her and her
costume were being covered in lubricant so
it wouldn’t rip.
The character’s look has come under attack
recently for being too revealing, while others
applaud its authenticity.
The actress has mentioned the outfit was uncomfortable
and ripped in some pretty awkward places.
But for her, the character’s appeal lies
in who she is, not what she wears.
And besides, Psylocke didn't even choose that
outfit, Apocalypse did.
Conclusion
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any actors who hated their superhero
costumes?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more videos like this one.